Thank you for listening to The Rest Is History. For weekly bonus episodes, ad-free listening, early access to series, and membership of our much-loved chat community, go to therestishistory.com and join the club. That is therestishistory.com. Can we do it? Yes, we can, Prime Minister. And though it is not my business to say so, we must. If we do not, or if we pussyfoot in our actions and do not achieve complete success, in another few months we shall be living in a totally different country
感谢您收听《历史其余》（The Rest Is History）。想要获取每周独家播客节目、无广告收听体验、系列节目的抢先收听特权，以及加入我们备受喜爱的聊天社区，请访问 therestishistory.com 并加入俱乐部。网址是 therestishistory.com。我们能做到吗？是的，我们可以，首相。虽然这不是我分内该说的话，但我们必须这么做。如果我们不这么做，或者我们在行动中畏首畏尾，未能取得彻底的成功，再过几个月，我们将生活在一个完全不同的国家
whose word will count for little. That, Dominic Sandbrook, was Mrs Thatcher and Sir Henry Leach, the first sea lord, debating what to do in the wake of the capture of the Falkland Islands by an Argentine invasion force. Tom, that was an extraordinary performance. That was, it wasn't quite on the level of your John Wayne, John Wayne as Genghis Khan that we had the other week, but it was up there. Thank you. And there will be more to come
它的言论将无足轻重。多米尼克·桑德布鲁克，那是撒切尔夫人和第一海务大臣亨利·利奇爵士在辩论：在阿根廷入侵部队攻占福克兰群岛之后，应该采取什么行动。汤姆，那是一次非凡的表演。那表现，虽然还达不到你模仿约翰·韦恩的水平——就是我们前几天听到的约翰·韦恩版成吉思汗，但也算相当不错了。谢谢。接下来还会有更多精彩内容
over the course of this exciting series. Are you going to be doing General Galtieri? No, no, but there will be more Thatcher. And I'm hoping to do an Ian MacDonald as well, who was the Ministry of Defence spokesman. So, Dominic, that was a kind of sneak preview of the reaction in London. But before we get to London and how people in government and the opposition and the media responded to the humiliation
在这个激动人心的系列节目中。你们会讲加尔铁里将军吗？不，不会，但会有更多关于撒切尔的内容。我还希望能讲讲伊恩·麦克唐纳，他是国防部发言人。所以，多米尼克，那算是对伦敦各界反应的一场抢先看。但在我们谈到伦敦、政府、反对派和媒体如何对这一奇耻大辱做出反应之前
of the loss of the Falklands, we left it. On a cliffhanger. So Rex Hunt holed up in Government House and and the Argentines have arrived so what happens so there's sort of hours of of of shooting um the we left it exactly that with the governor Rex Hunt um he's holed up he's got his shotgun uh the or he's got a uh he's actually got a got a pistol because his driver has got a shotgun and the raw marines and they are surrounded they're about i don't know five ten times as many argentine soldiers who have just landed um at the beginning of um in the early hours of uh friday the 2nd of april 1982 and basically the marines are completely outnumbered they don't formally surrender they
福克兰群岛失守，我们的故事停在了。一个悬念上。雷克斯·亨特把自己关在总督府里，阿根廷人已经到了，接下来会发生什么？所以大约有几个小时的交火，呃，我们当时讲到这里，总督雷克斯·亨特，呃，他把自己关在里面，拿着他的猎枪，呃，或者说他拿了一把，其实他拿的是一把手枪，因为他的司机有一把猎枪，还有皇家海军陆战队，他们被包围了，对方大约有——我不知道——五到十倍于他们的阿根廷士兵，他们刚刚在——在1982年4月2日星期五的清晨——登陆，基本上海军陆战队在人数上完全处于劣势，他们并没有正式投降，他们
don't want to do that but he orders them in his capacity basically the governor to lay down their weapons to avoid future bloodshed and then we have this moment so this is the early hours of friday morning and then we have this moment that we had at the in the first podcast in this series uh the argentines invade the little radio station that is broadcasting the news to all the people at the Falklands. They then argue among themselves. While they're doing that, Rex Hunt rings the radio station and he says, I'm dreadfully sorry this has happened.
不想那样做，但他以总督的身份命令他们放下武器，以避免未来发生流血冲突，然后我们迎来了这一幕——这是周五清晨的早些时候——然后我们迎来了我们在本系列第一集播客中提到的一幕：阿根廷人突袭了那个向福克兰群岛所有居民广播新闻的小型广播电台。然后他们自己争论起来。正当他们这么做的时候，雷克斯·亨特打电话给广播电台，他说，发生这种事我感到非常遗憾。
Very convenient for everybody. But he sort of, he has these wonderful last lines. He says, I'm sorry it's happened this way. This is probably the last message I'll be able to give you, but I wish you all the best of luck and rest assured that the British will be be back and of course this sounds like empty bravado but i think he means it um so about 10 o'clock that morning argentine helicopters arrive outside government house and and dominic could i actually quote sir rex hunt as quoted by
对所有人来说都很方便。但他有点——他说了这些精彩的临别赠言。他说，很遗憾事情会变成这样。这可能是我能向大家发布的最后一条消息了，但我祝大家一切顺利，请放心，英国人一定会回来的。当然，这听起来像是空洞的虚张声势，但我认为他是认真的。所以那天早上10点左右，阿根廷直升机抵达总督府外，多米尼克，我能引用雷克斯·亨特爵士的话吗？——正如你在你那本精彩的著作《敢作敢为》（Who Dares Wins）中所引用的那样：
you in your fabulous book who dares wins um out poured a horde of red-hatted gold-braided gentlemen who proceeded to hug kiss and embrace each other in typical latin fashion so i think you can see there why sir rex hunt was not a top diplomat no no why he had to be exiled to the but he then but he then he behaves very well rex hunts so he then goes along and he's introduced he goes to the town hall which is now completely occupied by Argentine troops and there is General Osvaldo Garcia who's the commander of the occupying force and
“涌现出一群戴着红帽子、满身金色穗带的绅士，他们开始像典型的拉丁人那样互相拥抱、亲吻。”所以我想你能看出为什么雷克斯·亨特爵士不是顶级外交官了，不，不，为什么他必须被流放到——但他随后——但雷克斯·亨特表现得非常好：他随后去了市政厅，那里现在完全被阿根廷军队占领了，占领军司令奥斯瓦尔多·加西亚将军就在那里，
Garcia holds out his hand, Rex Hunt describes him as a sallow little man and Garcia holds out his hand to Hunt to shake so the Argentines who described in the first podcast as being very badly behaved in their own country sort of electrocuting people and stuff. One of the strange things is they're actually pretty chivalrous.
加西亚伸出手，雷克斯·亨特形容他是一个面色蜡黄的小个子男人，加西亚向亨特伸出手要求握手。所以阿根廷人——正如在第一集播客中所描述的，他们在自己的国家表现非常糟糕，电击别人什么的。奇怪的事情之一是，他们实际上相当有骑士风度。
It's very important to them that they're perceived to be chivalrous by the British. Gentlemen. Yeah. They basically want the British to say, oh, well played. You know, this is a good sport. Because Argentina is a country where that idea of the british gentleman still has some currency it does it does play all that kind of stuff yes exactly and and there's this extraordinary thing where garcia holds out his hand rex hunt refuses to shake it and garcia says it is very ungentlemanly of you to refuse to shake my hand
他们非常看重英国人是否认为他们有骑士风度。绅士。是的。他们基本上希望英国人说，哦，干得漂亮。你知道，这很有体育精神。因为阿根廷是一个英国绅士的理念仍然有些流通的国家。确实如此，它确实行得通，诸如此类。是的，完全是这样。而且发生了一件很不寻常的事：加西亚伸出手，雷克斯·亨特拒绝握手，加西亚说：“你拒绝和我握手，这太没绅士风度了。”
and hunt says well it's very uncivilized of you to invade my country fair enough and then hunt very impressively given that he's surrounded by men with automatic weapons he says to this bloke um you have landed unlawfully on british territory and i order you to remove yourselves and your troops forthwith which they don't do and they basically put him and his wife mavis um onto a son presumably the. What about their son? Presumably the son as well. Yeah, I don't know what happened to Tony, actually. He disappears from the story. Get out of doing his O-levels. Exactly.
亨特回答说：“你们入侵我的国家，这太不文明了。”说得好。接着，亨特展现出令人印象深刻的风度——考虑到他被一群手持自动武器的人包围着，他对这家伙说，呃，你们非法登陆了英国领土，我命令你们和你们的军队立即撤离。而他们并没有这么做，他们基本上把他和他的妻子梅维斯——送上了——大概是。他们的儿子呢？大概还有儿子吧。是的，我其实不知道托尼怎么了。他从故事中消失了。免于参加普通中等教育证书考试。没错。
But again, in the sort of 1950s Peter Sellers comedy sort of touch, so they say we're going to put you on a plane and fly you out. He insists on getting his ceremonial sword, his hat with ostrich feathers yeah and he has himself driven to the airport in his red london cab with the union jack fluttering and all the the street well all the streets i mean the one street is kind of lined with hundreds of um falkland islanders who are kind of clapping and crying and stuff and he and he and mavis have flown off into exile so britain to eventually to britain yes um so that meeting that you alluded to earlier that had actually happened
但同样地，带着一种20世纪50年代彼得·塞勒斯喜剧的色彩，他们说我们要把你送上飞机把你空运出去。他坚持要带上他的礼剑、戴着鸵鸟羽毛的帽子——是的——他坐着插着英国国旗飘扬的红色伦敦出租车去机场，沿街——或者说整条街，其实也就是那一条街——挤满了数百名福克兰群岛居民，他们一边鼓掌一边哭泣等等，他和梅维斯就这样飞往流亡生活——最终去了英国——是的。所以你刚才提到的那次会议，其实发生在
two days previously so in london people had known that this was coming because they'd had intelligence that the argentine fleet was steaming towards the Falkland Islands. You know, Margaret Thatcher's in the House of Commons. She's asked by John Nott, her defence secretary, to go to his room. He gives her the news. The room starts to fill with people. They're all absolutely ashen. And she says, we have to get these islands back. You know, when the Argentines arrive, we'll have to kick them out. And John Nott says, well, we can't. And actually the consensus, pretty much the political consensus is we can't and actually the consensus pretty much political consensus is we can't and it's at that moment that the door opens and in comes the first sea lord sir henry leach he's been inspecting ships he's just heard the news so he's still in his his outfit and he
两天前。所以在伦敦，人们已经预料到这一点了，因为他们得到了情报，称阿根廷舰队正向福克兰群岛全速驶去。你知道，玛格丽特·撒切尔正在下议院。她的国防大臣约翰·诺特请她去他的办公室。他把这个消息告诉了她。办公室里开始聚集了人。他们全都面色惨白。她说，我们必须夺回这些群岛。你知道，当阿根廷人到来时，我们必须把他们赶出去。约翰·诺特说，好吧，我们做不到。实际上，共识——政治上的共识几乎是——我们做不到。实际上，共识几乎是——政治上的共识几乎是——我们做不到。就在这时，门开了，第一海务大臣亨利·利奇爵士走了进来。他一直在视察舰船，刚刚听到这个消息，所以他仍然穿着他的制服，他
says that remark let's have a crack let's have a crack at johnny yeah well he it's not quite that tom because it's more melodramatic than that it's more apocalyptic he says if we don't do it we'll be living in a different country whose word will count for little yeah and and he and he's the son of a commander in the second world war who had died on hms prince of wales okay so shot by the japanese and what was then a sort of landmark humiliation and and leach joined the Navy as a boy. And all his life, I think, has been, you know, it's that kind of thing that you-
说出了那句名言：让我们去大干一场吧，给约翰尼一点颜色看看。是的，好吧，汤姆，其实没那么简单，因为这比那更具戏剧性，更具末日色彩。他说，如果我们不这么做，我们将生活在一个不同的国家，它的言论将无足轻重。是的，而且他是二战中一位在威尔士亲王号战列舰上牺牲的指挥官的儿子，好吧。被日本人击沉了，当时这是一次具有里程碑意义的耻辱。利奇作为一个男孩加入了海军。我猜他的一生都在，你知道，就是那种你——
Once redemption. Has daydreamed about. And suddenly fate has delivered him a chance to, you know, avenge his father, prove himself worthy of his father. So he's head of the Navy. Yeah. And do the rest of the defence, the chiefs of defence staff, do they agree? They're all for it.
渴望救赎。梦想过的。命运突然给了他一个机会，去，你知道的，为他的父亲复仇，证明自己配得上他的父亲。所以他是海军最高长官。是的。那么其余的国防高层，也就是国防参谋长们，他们同意吗？他们完全赞同。
They're all for it. Okay. And Mrs. Thatcher, I mean, we haven't really talked about her much, partly because all her interest in her first sort of two and a half years as prime minister, all her interest has been in economic reform, in her harsh economic medicine. So, you know know of course she's she's very into the cold war she's very anti-communist all this stuff but you know a war
他们完全赞同。好的。至于撒切尔夫人，我的意思是，我们还没有真正过多地讨论她，部分原因在于她在担任首相的前两年半里，所有的兴趣都在于经济改革，在于她严厉的经济药方。所以，你知道，当然她非常投入冷战，她非常反共，诸如此类，但是你知道，一场
with argentina is the last thing that has ever been on her mind and it's an extraordinary thing this sort of transformation that happens to her because suddenly she is sort of transfigured into this you know she basically can dress up as Winston Churchill. She's, as you say, she's been very, very obsessed with economic matters, the kind of the social tensions that her economic policies have generated in Britain. But she is also a kind of very patriotic admirer of Kipling. Yeah.
与阿根廷的战争是她脑子里最不可能想到的事。这真是一件不可思议的事，这种发生在她身上的转变，因为她突然被某种东西——你知道，她基本上可以打扮成温斯顿·丘吉尔。正如你所说，她一直非常非常沉迷于经济事务，沉迷于她的经济政策在英国产生的社会紧张局势。但她同时也是一位非常爱国、崇拜吉卜林的人。是的。
Talks about Winston, all that kind of stuff. Winston. Winston. So presumably her instinct is to say we should do this. She has the chiefs of defence who also say, yes, we can do this. But she's surrounded by Tory grandees who, as we mentioned in the first episode, all seem to have won the military cross. So are clearly very brave men with experience of military service. But the impression I get is that by and large, they are less enthusiastic about it.
谈论温斯顿，诸如此类的事情。温斯顿。温斯顿。所以可以推测，她的直觉是说我们应该这么做。她拥有同样说“是的，我们能做到”的国防高官。但她被一些托利党显贵们包围着，正如我们在第一集里提到的，这些人似乎都获得过军功十字勋章。所以显然都是有过军事服役经验的非常勇敢的人。但我得到的印象是，总的来说，他们对此并没有那么热衷。
I think they are, actually. I think a lot of people, when her cabinet meet, so that's on the Friday night, so after the news of the invasion, the invasion has definitively happened. The cabinet has agreed to go for it, but I think they go for it much more reluctantly. She is all for it. She absolutely believes from the, from the very moment the invasion breaks, she absolutely believes Britain has to do it. You know,
我想他们确实如此。我认为很多人，当她的内阁开会时——那是周五晚上，在入侵的消息传出之后，入侵已经切实发生了。内阁已经同意放手一搏，但我认为他们做这个决定时要勉强得多。她是一心想打。从入侵爆发的那一刻起，她就坚信英国必须这么做。你知道，
it's as though this was the sort of, you know, Churchill famously, when he became prime minister said, you know, all my I'd been in preparation for this trial and all this stuff. I mean, I think there's a bit of Margaret Thatcher that – Failure? Do you remember what Queen Victoria once said? Failure? The possibilities do not exist. Exactly, exactly. And as the conflict goes on, she starts to play that part much more and more sort of self-confidently. But you're right that I think if she had said in that cabinet meeting on a Friday night,
这就好像——你知道，丘吉尔当年成为首相时曾有名言说，你知道，我的一生都在为这场考验做准备，诸如此类。我的意思是，我觉得玛格丽特·撒切尔身上有一点——失败？还记得维多利亚女王曾经说过的话吗？失败？根本不存在这种可能性。没错，没错。随着冲突的继续，她越来越自信地扮演这个角色。但你说得对，我想如果她在周五晚上的那次内阁会议上说，
well, there are all kinds of reasons why this would be very foolish to send a task force, then I think there'd been a lot of people. Quite relieved. Yeah, I think quite a few of her ministers said, yeah, you're quite right, Prime Minister. I'm insensible. Let's not overdo this. Let's not escalate. Now, interestingly, the Foreign Office,
好吧，有各种各样的理由说明派遣特遣舰队会非常愚蠢，那么我想会有很多人。如释重负。是的，我想她的不少大臣会说：“首相阁下，您说得对。我不太赞成。我们别做得过头了。不要升级局势。”现在，有趣的是，外交部——
who she absolutely despises as a kind of nest of appeasers, they send a preliminary assessment that night, the Friday night, that says Britain will not win international backing for using force. The United States will not support us. You know, we won't be able to persuade the British public it's worth it. It's just complete.
她绝对鄙视外交部，认为那里是绥靖主义者的温床——他们在当晚（周五晚）发了一份初步评估，称英国使用武力不会赢得国际支持。美国不会支持我们。你知道，我们无法说服英国公众这是值得的。这简直是一派胡言。
And to Mrs. Thatcher, she's like, what was the alternative? That a commoner garden dictator should rule over the queen's subjects and prevail by fraud and violence not while i was prime minister so she said she's saying that before the debate that is called for the first time in many many years on a saturday since sue is well well that's a kind of telling isn't it so very great humiliation and there and the house of commons is summoned on a saturday to debate what seems to be another catastrophic british humiliation and i think and i remember it vividly i remember it vividly because we were trying to set up a cricket net in our garden and our garden wasn't really big
而对撒切尔夫人来说，她的反应是：难道还有别的选择吗？难道要让一个普普通通的独裁者统治女王的臣民，并靠欺诈和暴力得逞吗？只要我还是首相，决不允许这种情况发生。所以她说，她在苏伊士运河事件以来许多许多年里第一次在星期六召开辩论之前，就这么说了。嗯，这很有说明意义，不是吗？那是一次巨大的耻辱，下议院在星期六被召集起来，辩论这起似乎又是一场灾难性的英国奇耻大辱。而且我想——我对此记忆犹新。我记忆犹新，因为我们当时正试图在花园里搭一个板球网，而我们的花园其实不够大——
enough to tell your life is beyond parody i mean i know i know so uh it was kind of tricky we had to kind of work out the angle so we could just about squeeze it in with all going up a hill and things it wasn't it wasn't very effective but um i remember while we were struggling with the nets and the polls and everything listening to the debate and it was it was my first experience of listening to a debate in Parliament. And it couldn't have been more dramatic. Of course. Because when she goes, people think she could fall. She could be toast.
你的生活简直像个讽刺。我知道，我知道。所以，这有点棘手，我们必须计算好角度，才能勉强把它塞进去，还得顺着一个小坡什么的。它其实没多大效果，但是，我记得当我们跟球网、杆子以及所有东西较劲时，听着那场辩论。那是我第一次经历听国会辩论。而且它不可能更具戏剧性了。当然。因为当她去的时候，人们认为她可能会倒台。她可能会完蛋。
Because it is humiliating. Yeah, it's a humiliation. It's a total humiliation. And she's answerable for it. Yeah, absolutely. It happened on her watch. Intelligence failure happened. Now, you know, how much is she personally responsible
因为这是一种耻辱。是的，这是一个耻辱。这是一场彻底的耻辱。而她要为此负责。是的，绝对的。这在她任内发生了。情报失败发生了。现在，你知道，她个人要承担多大责任——
we're not really well the buck stops with the prime minister absolutely so in other words had she been in opposition and had it happened to james callahan or michael foot she would have been the first to lead the prosecution so it's completely reasonable that she takes the blame um she gives at first quite a tentative performance because she knows that she's going to get a lot of flack the press that morning is awful for the government says you know this is the worst humiliation in british history but there's also right away an absolute sense in the press we you know this is world war ii we have to fight i mean the express i always think the express had a front page which in a weird way i mean this probably says a lot about me that i've always found quite
我们其实没有——好吧，最高责任在首相。绝对的。换句话说，如果她当时在反对党，而这事发生在詹姆斯·卡拉汉或迈克尔·富特身上，她会是第一个带头起诉的人。所以她承担责备是完全合理的。一开始，她的表现有些试探性，因为她知道自己会遭到很多抨击。那天早上的媒体对政府极其不友好，说这是英国历史上最耻辱的事。但与此同时，媒体中也立即涌现出一种绝对的共识：我们——你知道，这是二战，我们必须战斗。我的意思是，《快报》——我一直认为《快报》有一期头版，用一种奇怪的方式——这可能很能说明我一直觉得它挺感人的——
moving which is that they had the whole front page was a photograph taken a few years earlier they'd for some thing some feature they'd managed to get every single falkland islander on the lawn outside government house and they're all waving union jacks and looking up and they're being photographed from above and so the express ran that picture again on its full on its front page with the um the headline our loyal subjects we must defend them and this so right so so um the foreign office had said public opinion won't be in favor of a task force and straight away public and straight away public opinion is kind of swinging behind it now the other key constituency of course is the opposition yeah and the opposition is led by
那就是他们的整个头版是一张几年前拍摄的照片，当时为了某个专题，他们设法把福克兰群岛的每一个居民都请到了总督府外面的草坪上，他们都在挥舞着英国国旗，抬头仰望，照片是从上方拍摄的。所以《快报》在其头版完整地再次刊登了这张照片，配上的标题是：“我们忠诚的臣民，我们必须保卫他们。”所以你看，外交部曾说过公众舆论不会支持特遣舰队，而转眼间，公众舆论却开始转向支持了。现在，另一个关键群体当然是反对党，是的。反对党由
michael foot who is um very distinguished political cultural literary figure uh wonderful books on byron and jonathan swift hazlitt and swift and all kinds of things very very civilized man um he had he he's definitely on the the left of the party and so it it's it's not immediately obvious that he is going to swing behind demands for the falklands to be taken back but But he does. And he has this wonderful phrase you quote from him, I know a fascist when I see one. Because as a young man,
迈克尔·富特（Michael Foot）领导，他是一位非常杰出的政治、文化和文学人物，写过关于拜伦、乔纳森·斯威夫特、赫兹里特和斯威夫特的精彩著作，以及各种各样的书。他是一个非常有教养的人。他绝对属于党内的左翼，所以他是否会顺应夺回福克兰群岛的要求，并不是显而易见的。但他确实顺应了。你引用过他的一句精彩的话：“当我看到法西斯分子时，我一眼就能认出来。”因为作为一个年轻人，
he had been very opposed to appeasement, hadn't he? Yeah, he'd made his name with the pamphlet Guilty Men, attacking the appeasers in the late 1930s. And he sees himself as a very anti-fascist. So Michael Foote gives this, Mrs. Thatcher gives a tentative speech. Michael Foote gives this absolutely blazing speech um you know he says the four glories have been have been faced with an
他非常反对绥靖政策，对吧？是的，他在20世纪30年代末通过小册子《罪人》（Guilty Men）攻击绥靖派而崭露头角。他把自己视为坚定的反法西斯主义者。所以迈克尔·富特发表了——撒切尔夫人发表了一场试探性的演讲。迈克尔·富特发表了一场极其慷慨激昂的演讲，你知道，他说，福克兰群岛人民面对的是
act of naked unqualified aggression carried out in the most shameful and disreputable circumstances they have the absolute right to look to us at this moment of their desperate plight just as they have looked to us for the past 150 years all this kind of thing and the tour is love it i mean they're all cheering everybody's cheering some of his own but but not not everybody right no i know because there are people on that well there are two famous figures on the left who are opposed to it the first the first and it will not surprise anyone is an obscure left-wing mp from islington called jeremy corbyn no he's not mp yet he's not an mp yet he's he's about to be adopted as the as labor's candidate in islington and he he he condemns foot as a kind of errant imperialist and dismisses the whole idea of sending a task
赤裸裸的、毫无保留的侵略行为，这是在最可耻、最声名狼藉的环境下进行的。在他们绝望的困境中，他们拥有绝对的权利指望我们，就像他们过去150年来一直指望我们一样，诸如此类的话。保守党人爱死这番话了——我是说，他们都在欢呼，每个人都在欢呼，他自己党内也有人——但并不是所有人，对吧？不，我知道，因为在那——党内有两名著名的左翼人士对此表示反对。第一个——这不会让任何人感到意外——是伊斯灵顿的一名鲜为人知的左翼下议院议员，名叫杰里米·科尔宾。不，他当时还不是议员。他当时还不是议员，他即将被采纳为工党在伊斯灵顿的候选人。他
force as a tory plot to keep their money-making friends in business. But of course, the standard bearer of the left in opposition to foot is Tony Benn. And Tony Benn comes out very much against it. Michael's an absolute warmonger. But what I learned from your book is that in 1976, when Benn himself had been in government, he wondered what would happen in the event of an Argentine invasion. And he said the total spinelessness of the foreign office and the general decay of Britain would prevent it being taken back. So that's quite a swing in perspective. It is, exactly. So what's going on there?
谴责富特是一个误入歧途的帝国主义者，并斥责派遣特遣舰队的整个想法是保守党为了让其赚钱的朋友们维持生意而搞的阴谋。但当然，反对富特的左翼旗手是托尼·本恩（Tony Benn）。托尼·本恩对此坚决反对。迈克尔是个彻头彻尾的好战分子。但我从你的书里学到的是，在1976年，本恩本人还在政府任职时，他曾想过如果发生阿根廷入侵会怎么样。他说，外交部的彻底软弱无能和英国的全面衰落将阻止英国将其夺回。所以这是一个相当大的视角转变。确实如此，完全是这样。那么那里到底发生了什么？
Why is he... Well, Tony, Ben is on this sort of conveyor belt that is moving him ever leftwards. So that is not the reflection of the fact that he's... Oh, but it is also the reflection of the fact, yeah. Okay, so there's a slight degree of hypocrisy, but it is also reflected that he's moving further to the left. I think there is a bit of a degree of hypocrisy, actually. I know some listeners may be great Tony Benn fans.
为什么他会……好吧，托尼·本恩正处于一条不断把他推向更左立场的传送带上。所以这并不反映他——哦，但这同时也反映了这样一个事实，是的。好吧，有一定的虚伪程度，但也反映出他正在向更左的方向发展。我认为实际上确实有一定程度的虚伪。我知道有些听众可能是托尼·本恩的狂热粉丝。
You know, Tony Benn gets a lot of stick at this point from other people, by the way, on the left of the Labour Party. So Eric Heffer, for example, who ought to be one of his allies, says basically these people say to him, what is wrong with you? Can you not see that the Argentines are, by our lights, we see them as fascists. We should be absolutely against them. And somebody says, you know, if we carry on with your, we'll be known as the Munich Party and all this kind of stuff. So, yeah, I mean, certainly what you have, and we can get into this maybe later on when we talk about the public and the press, is you have clearly a division, which was also there at Suez, actually,
你知道，托尼·本恩此时受到了工党内其他人的严厉批评。比如埃里克·赫弗（Eric Heffer），他本该是他的盟友之一，基本上对他说：你到底怎么了？难道你看不出按照我们的标准，阿根廷人就是法西斯吗？我们应该坚决反对他们。有人说，你知道，如果我们继续你的那一套，我们会被称为慕尼黑党，诸如此类的话。所以，是的，我的意思是，当然，你所看到的——我们稍后在谈论公众和媒体时可能会深入这一点——你清楚地看到了一种分裂，这在苏伊士运河事件中其实也存在，
going back to what you were saying about the Saturday meeting of the House of Commons, between that part of the Labour coalition that is kind of working class Labour voters. Set up NATO. Yeah. Yeah. And then on the other hand, you have the high minded, you know, people who live in leafy, you know, university towns. So horrified by the thought of the very idea of going to war with anybody.
回到你刚才关于下议院星期六会议的说法，这种分裂存在于工党联盟中那些工人阶级工党选民之间。他们建立了北约。是的。是的。而另一方面，你又有那些思想高尚的、住在绿树成荫的大学镇里的人。他们对与任何人开战的想法感到无比恐惧。
Right. And so they're not just in the Labour Party, are they? They're also, so we've got, um the sdp and the liberals so they are um they've they've come together in an alliance they they seem to be knocking huge chunks out of both the tories and labor and they're led by roy jenkins yeah who um have you got a nice quote about roy jenkins i do i do i do which i have lifted again from your book and this is by um parliamentary sketch writer called frank johnson brilliant writer every parliamentary sketch writer i know kind of i think tim stanley who telegraph telegraph
没错。所以他们不仅仅在工党里，对吧？他们还在——我们有社会民主党（SDP）和自由党。他们联合成了一个联盟，他们似乎在保守党和工党身上都挖走了大片选民。他们由罗伊·詹金斯（Roy Jenkins）领导。是的，你有一句关于罗伊·詹金斯的精彩引言吗？我有，我有，我有。我再次从你的书里摘录了这段话，这是由一位名叫弗兰克·约翰逊（Frank Johnson）的议会速写作家写的，他是个才华横溢的作家。我认识的每一位议会速写作家——我想《每日电讯报》的蒂姆·斯坦利——目前《电讯报》的速写作家形容他为议会速写作家中的莫扎特。他——
currently the telegraph sketch writer described him as the mozart of parliamentary sketch writers and he he um he he describes roy roy jenkins as um a one-man Switzerland, as prosperous, comfortable, civilized, and almost entirely landlocked. His only previous contact with the high seas had been in various good fish restaurants. And obviously, he, you know, in a slightly different way to Tony Benn, but he also is, you know, he's not suited to Nelsonian exploits and the waving of Union Jacks and things no absolutely not and I think so what you have there is a Jenkins Roy Jenkins who was a colossal figure in the imagination of the 1970s and 19
他把罗伊·詹金斯描述为一个人的瑞士：富裕、舒适、文明，且几乎完全不临海。他唯一一次与公海的接触是在各种好的海鲜餐厅里。显然，他——以一种与托尼·本恩略有不同的方式——也同样不适合纳尔逊式的壮举和挥舞英国国旗之类的事情。不，绝对不适合。我想，这就是为什么你会看到罗伊·詹金斯——他在20世纪70年代和19年代初的想象中是一个庞然大物，
early 1980s because he's the absolute incarnation of kind of metropolitan um liberalism and uh civilized not not not not sort of capital l left wing but kind of mildly center left good chaps fine wines restaurants in brussels kind of kind of um remainers civilized metropolitan remainers absolutely absolutely he thinks this is backward you know it's atavist it as primitive atavism to be fighting a war over faraway islands to be waving the flag to be sending fleets utterly it's vulgar he's completely uncomfortable with it and there are people within his own party the sdp so british listeners some of them will know david owen for example um former foreign secretary yeah who is all for the falklands War.
因为他是大都会自由主义和文明的绝对化身——不是那种大写的左翼，而是温和的中左翼、好小伙、优质葡萄酒、布鲁塞尔的餐厅、留欧派、文明的大都会留欧派。绝对是这样。他认为这是落后的（你知道，为遥远的岛屿打仗、挥舞国旗、派遣舰队是一种原始的返祖现象），这太粗俗了。他对此感到极度不适。他的党内（即社会民主党）也有这样的人，比如英国听众中的一些人会知道大卫·欧文（David Owen），前外交大臣，他全力支持福克兰群岛战争。
He thinks, you know, go for it, embrace it. David Owen was kind of blue Labour, wasn't he? I mean, that's the division. So suddenly, Mrs Thatcher, I mean, Michael Foote has let her off the hook in the House of Commons, by the way, on the Saturday. By attacking the Argentines, really, rather than the government's intelligence failure, he's given her a bit of an opportunity. But it's clear that people i mean this is not a top-down thing at all the public are not brainwashed they're not led they're pushing for it the public i mean instantly you see it on the ground that um in in diaries in in in actually
他认为，你知道，大干一场吧，拥抱它。大卫·欧文算是一种“蓝色工党”，不是吗？我的意思是，这就是分歧所在。所以突然之间，撒切尔夫人——顺便说一句，迈克尔·富特在周六的下议院辩论中放了她一马。通过攻击阿根廷人而不是政府的情报失误，他实际上给了她一个机会。但很明显，人们——我的意思是，这根本不是一个自上而下的过程，公众并没有被洗脑，也没有被引导，而是他们在推动这一切。公众——我的意思是，你在实地立刻就能看到，在日记里，在——
the turnout of the docs when the task force leave um so that that weekend the task force already mobilizing for war they're already you know trucks piling into kind of portsmouth and southampton with equipment people being recalled all the ships being requisitioned and when they leave the the the key sides are packed with wives and girlfriends kissing and yeah. Ordinary people, though, waving flags and crying and singing patriotic songs and all this sort of stuff. So the task force does go and there are enough ships. You know, this has happened before the cuts have bitten. So we do, the British, we, I'm turning to the BBC, the British, the British do have enough ships to send a credible naval force yes uh so so these these are destroyers and aircraft carriers but also requisitioned uh ferries that are carrying the
特遣舰队离开时码头的人头攒动——所以在那个周末，特遣舰队已经在为战争做动员了，卡车已经满载设备驶入朴茨茅斯和南安普顿，人员被召回，所有的船只都被征用。当他们离开时，码头挤满了亲吻着的妻子和女友——是的。普通人挥舞着旗帜、哭泣、唱着爱国歌曲等等。所以特遣舰队确实出发了，而且有足够的舰船。你知道，这是在预算削减产生严重影响之前发生的。所以我们确实——英国人——我转向BBC——英国人、英国人确实有足够的舰船来派遣一支可信的海军力量。是的——所以这些是驱逐舰和航空母舰，还有被征用的、运送军队的
troops well cruise ships so basically the two biggest so you've got two aircraft carriers that go which are hermes and invincible the two aircraft carriers that john knott had wanted to scrap and then they requisition the canberra, which is I think a P&O liner. And they're going to put on, the Canberra is going to have the Vanguard, which is called three commando brigade, which has got three Royal Marine battalions, two paratrooper battalions.
渡轮，还有邮轮。基本上是最大的两艘——所以有两艘航空母舰出征，分别是“竞技神”号和“无敌”号，这两艘航母正是约翰·诺特之前想要废弃的。然后他们征用了“堪培拉”号，我想这是一艘P&O公司的豪华客轮。他们要把“先锋”号——也就是所谓的第三突击旅，里面包含三个皇家海军陆战队营、两个伞兵营——部署到“堪培拉”号上去。
So that's about three to 4,000 men. And they're going to be taken on the Canberra. So you have, but you've also got all these support ships. So, you know, it's a sort of fleet it's a d-day style fleet because the logistics obviously are the Falklands are in the middle of nowhere you have to take everything with you yeah so there's this huge armada well there is there's Ascension Island isn't there in the middle of yeah the Atlantic is in the middle of the Atlantic that's British but it has an American base on it we've leased a base yeah so the amount we need the Americans on side right so the task force sets off um there's there's a kind
所以大约有三到四千人。他们将乘坐“堪培拉”号前往。所以你不仅拥有这些，你还拥有所有这些支援舰船。所以，你知道，这是一支舰队，这是一支D日（诺曼底登陆）风格的舰队，因为后勤显然是个问题，福克兰群岛在荒郊野岭，你必须把一切都随身携带。所以有这么大的一支舰队——哦，大西洋中间有个阿森松岛，对吧？是的，大西洋中间有阿森松岛，那是英国的，但上面有一个美军基地，我们租借了一个基地。所以我们需要美国人站在我们这一边，对吧？因此，特遣舰队出发了，有一种
of growing sense of uh patriotism and i guess that um some people would say jingoism and that sense of the of a division i mean it's not as strong as you get, say, with the Brexit vote, but there are certain kind of parallels there, I guess, that are expressed through a wonderful collection of essays by Britain's writers. So Polly Toynbee, the Guardian columnist, and Margaret Drabble, the Hampstead novelist, and Salman Rushdie, of course. It's called Authors Take Sides on the Falklands. It was done in imitation of one from the Spanish Civil War. So they're all against the task force. Oh, it's brilliant, actually. But my favourite one that you quote is Jilly Cooper,
日益增长的爱国主义情绪，我想有些人会称之为沙文主义，还有那种分裂感——我的意思是，它没有像比如脱欧公投那样强烈，但我想其中存在某些相似之处，这通过英国作家的一系列精彩随笔表达了出来。比如《卫报》专栏作家波利·托因比（Polly Toynbee）、汉普斯特德小说家玛格丽特·德拉布（Margaret Drabble），当然还有萨尔曼·鲁西迪。这本书名叫《作家们就福克兰群岛表态》（Authors Take Sides on the Falklands）。它是模仿西班牙内战时期的一本书制作的。所以他们都反对特遣舰队。哦，其实这很精彩。但我最喜欢你引用的一个作家是吉莉·库珀（Jilly Cooper），
author of Bonkbuster novels. She clearly sends her contribution in late because the war looks like it's already happened. I have to confess, some of these Argentinian officers are so frightfully good looking, one might almost enjoy being taken prisoner by them. Yeah, of course. So that's her take on it. But all the others that you mentioned, like Rushdie, Polly Toynbee, Margaret Preble.
畅销通俗小说作家。她显然交稿很晚，因为当时战争看起来已经打完了。“我必须承认，有些阿根廷军官长得实在是太帅了，以至于人们甚至可能会有点享受被他们俘虏的过程。”是的，当然。这就是她的看法。但你提到的其他人，比如鲁西迪、波利·托因比、玛格丽特·德拉布——
They're all against it. I mean, it's not just that they're against it, Tom. And this is how it does preview the Brexit argument. It is that they think they find it utterly unthinkable it's and it's embarrassing and vulgar but it's also turns on their head on its on on on its head everything they had thought about what britain was and they had thought that britain had turned its back on this sort of stuff you've got this fabulous quote again in your book from jonathan rabban fabulous travel writer. I'd heard Britain talking in a dream, he says, after watching the task
他们都反对。我的意思是，汤姆，这不仅仅是反对那么简单。这就是它如何预示了脱欧辩论的地方。他们觉得这完全不可思议，既尴尬又粗俗，但这也颠覆了他们对英国是什么的所有固有看法。他们曾以为英国已经对这种事情背道而驰了。你再次在书中引用了乔纳森·拉班（Jonathan Raban）的一段精彩引言，他是一位杰出的旅行作家。“我觉得自己像是在梦里听到了英国的声音，”他在目睹特遣舰队起航后说道，“而它所说的话让我吓得魂不附体。”
floors set sail, and what it was saying scared me stiff. Although part of the reason I think why he's scared stiff is that he actually finds himself moved by it, doesn't he? I think that's what's so brilliant. So do you know the brilliant thing about the Falklands from a historian's point of view is that that spring, two different brilliant travel writers that had the same idea. Paul Theroux was one and Jonathan Rabin was the other. And they both had the idea of sailing around the coast of the island of Great Britain and dropping in at kind of seaside towns and writing about, I guess, largely for an American audience, about what they found. And I think they both thought of this idea independently as Britain is a declining nation.
尽管我认为他吓得魂不附体的原因之一，其实是他发现自己被它打动了，不是吗？我想这正是它如此精彩的地方。所以你知道福克兰群岛从历史学家的角度来看最精彩的地方是什么吗？那年春天，两位不同的杰出旅行作家有了同一个想法。保罗·索鲁（Paul Theroux）是一个，乔纳森·拉班是另一个。他们都有这样一个想法：乘船环游大不列颠岛的海岸，在海滨小镇停留，并把他们的所见所闻写下来——我想主要是写给美国观众看的。我想他们俩都不约而同地认为英国是一个衰落的国家。
You know, it'll be old pensioners moaning about inflation and stuff and the empire having gone. And they both set off on sort of different routes. And the war breaks out while they're doing it. So, and the most amazing, Jonathan Rabin's book is called Sailing. And there's this, as you, I'm so glad you mentioned this because it's an amazing section
你知道，这只会是老年退休人员抱怨通货膨胀、抱怨帝国消逝。于是他们分别踏上了不同的路线。而战争就在他们这样做的时候爆发了。所以，最令人惊叹的是——乔纳森·拉班的书名叫《航行》（Sailing）。这里有——正如你所说，我太高兴你提到这个了，因为这是一个惊人的段落，
where he talks about watching, he's on his boat and he's watching the task force sailing on a little sort of black and white telly or something. And he thinks, his brain thinks it's ridiculous. We shouldn't be doing this. But his heart is going. Yeah. And then he notices that he's crying, his brain thinks it's ridiculous we shouldn't be doing this but his heart is going yeah and then
他在书中谈到自己观看——他在自己的船上，通过一台小小的黑白电视机之类的东西看着特遣舰队航行。他的大脑认为这太荒谬了。我们不应该这样做。但他的心却在狂跳。然后他注意到自己哭了。他的大脑认为这太荒谬了，我们不应该这样做，但他的心却在狂跳。然后他注意到
he notices that that he's crying you know with with emotion at the sort of the the anthem singing and all that sort of stuff um yeah and i think uh you're absolutely right that there's there's a very much a kind of brexit ish yeah divide although it's different because in this case it's about 80 percent of the public are all for it. And the polls suggest that, I think the most amazing polls say that four out of 10 people wanted Britain to just start bombing Argentina straight away. And two out of 10 people thought Britain should invade Argentina itself. Yeah. So, you know, the public...
自己因为伴随国歌声等各种情感而流泪……是的，我认为你说得绝对没错，这非常具有类似脱欧的分裂色彩，尽管有所不同，因为在这种情况下，大约80%的公众都全力支持。民意调查显示——我认为最惊人的民意调查显示，十分之四的人希望英国直接开始轰炸阿根廷。十分之我有两人认为英国应该亲自入侵阿根廷。所以，你知道，公众……
So that's the Eric Banks equivalent of... Exactly. Okay. We should, I think, take a break at this point. And when we come back as as the task force steams its way across the atlantic let's look at the international context uh because that becomes very important okay i'm marina hyde and i'm richard osmond and together we host the rest is entertainment it's your weekly fix of entertainment news reviews splash of show
这相当于埃里克·班克斯（Eric Banks）版本的……没错。好吧，我想我们此时应该休息一下。当我们回来时，随着特遣舰队横渡大西洋，让我们来看看国际背景，因为这变得非常重要。好的，我是玛丽娜·海德（Marina Hyde），我是理查德·奥斯曼（Richard Osman），我们共同主持《其余皆娱乐》（The Rest Is Entertainment）。这是你们每周必看的娱乐新闻、评论、八卦节目，在我们的问答环节中，我们将揭开娱乐界的神秘面纱，告诉你们这一切是如何运作的。我们刚刚启动了会员俱乐部。如果你想要无广告收听、独家节目和优先购买现场票的权利，请访问 therestisentertainment.com。网址是 therestisentertainment.com。你好，欢迎回到《历史其余》。我们现在正处于福克兰群岛战争的核心。
biz gossip and on our q a we pull back the curtain on entertainment and we tell you how it all works. We have just launched our Members Club. If you want ad-free listening, bonus episodes, and early access to live tickets, head to therestisentertainment.com. That's therestisentertainment.com. Hello, welcome back to The Rest Is History. We are in the heart of the Falklands War now.
特遣舰队已经起航。当然，这在很大程度上是一场国际冲突。我的意思是，我认为世界各地的人们、世界各地的政府都在以某种程度的困惑注视着英国发起这场看似——嗯，我的意思是，它基本上是一场殖民战争。在英国国内，多米尼克，这里的背景是约翰·诺特留任了，但卡灵顿勋爵辞职了。是这样吗？是的。约翰·诺特想辞职，但撒切尔夫人不准。他对此非常愤慨，因为他认为这让他名誉扫地。所以约翰·诺特是国防大臣。
The task force has set sail. And of course, this is very much an international conflict. I mean, I think people around the world, governments around the world, are looking in a certain degree of perplexity as Britain launches what seems, well, I mean, it is basically a colonial war. And within Britain, Dominic, the context for this is that John Lott has stayed in position, but Lord Carrington has resigned. Is that right? That's right. John Lott wanted to resign, but Mrs. Thatcher wouldn't let him. And he really resented that because he thought it made him dishonorable. So John Lott's the defence secretary.
但外交大臣卡灵顿勋爵——讽刺的是，他是唯一一个预见到入侵并说“我们必须——你知道，我们必须提防这一点”的人——尽管如此，出于这种荣誉感，他还是引咎辞职了。所以这是一件非常光彩的事。他被弗朗西斯·皮姆（Francis Pym）取代了。撒切尔夫人讨厌他。他也是个战争英雄，对吧？的确，是的。
But the foreign secretary, Lord Carrington, who ironically was the one person who had foreseen the invasion and said, we have to be, you know, we have to watch out for this. He nevertheless, because he's out of this sort of sense of honour, he falls on his sword. So it is a very honourable thing. So he gets replaced by Francis Pym. Who Mrs Thatcher hates. Who's another war hero, right? Who is, indeed, yes.
但他看起来——他是个那种油腔滑调的托利党伊顿公学毕业生。好吧，他们看起来都挺油腔滑调的。他看起来特别油腔滑调。他显然在发胶（Brylcreem）公司有股份。是的。而且，我的意思是，如果撒切尔夫人倒台，他是最有可能接替她的人。是的，大概是的。所以对于让他在内阁里，她有点如坐针毡。
But he looks, he's a kind of, he's one of those slimy-looking Tory-Etonians. Well, they're all pretty slimy-looking. He looks particularly slimy. He's got shares in Brylcreem, clearly. Yeah. And he is, I mean, he's the likeliest to succeed Thatcher if she falls. Yes, probably, yeah. So she's a bit twitchy about having him on board.
绝对是的。而且他比撒切尔或诺特要温和一些。不过，汤姆，她在这一方面的名声被严重漫画化了。你看，我们后来可能在随后的关于这一切对选举影响的节目中看到的那种普遍形象——撒切尔夫人自己也符合这种“铁娘子”形象：毫不妥协、坚决果断、决意开战（你知道，我们不谈判，我们要战斗，所有这种想法）——这与文献记录、与档案现实完全不符。
Absolutely, yeah. And also he's a little bit wetter than Thacher or not. Although, Tom, her reputation in this regard is massively caricatured. You see, the common image we can get later into the, and probably a subsequent episode about the electoral impact of all this but the image of mrs thatcher that she herself colluded in the iron lady image um unbending determined bent on war you know we we will not talk we will fight all this sort of idea is utterly at variance with the documentary record, with the archival reality.
好吧，很明显，从一开始她就对妥协持开放态度，英国政府对妥协持开放态度，实际上对妥协的想法非常热衷。现在，他们不想在事后承认这一点，特别是当战争胜利后，所有关于这一点的提及时基本上都被抹去了。所以立刻，英国没有国际支持就无法成功——因此他们做的第一件非常聪明的事，就是在这个第一个周末，英国驻联合国大使安东尼·帕森斯爵士（Sir Anthony Parsons）让安全理事会通过了
Well, it's very clear that from the beginning, she was open to compromise, that the British government was open to compromise, and was actually very keen on the idea of compromise. Now, they didn't want to omit this later on, because particularly when the war was won, all mention of this was basically banished. So right away, it's that britain cannot succeed without international support so the first thing they do which is really smart is straight away the first weekend that britain's ambassador to the united nations sir anthony parsons gets the security council to
很显然，从一开始她就持妥协态度，英国政府也持妥协态度，实际上非常渴望妥协。现在，他们不想在后来省略这一点，因为特别是在战争胜利之后，所有关于这方面的提及基本上都被根除了。所以马上，英国没有国际支持就无法成功，因此他们做的第一件真正聪明的事情就是，在第一个周末，英国常驻联合国代表安东尼·帕森斯爵士就让安理会...
approve a resolution i think it's 502 um that they want the argentines to withdraw from the islands and that passes and that passes because doesn't the the soviet ambassador says to antifascists you deserve the garter for that yeah exactly that's very very good um uh nice thing for the soviet so the soviet union abstain because they hate argentina and britain equally as do china so the resolution passes now the amazing thing about this is the Argentine regime, the Galtieri regime, which we talked about in the last episode, is so incompetent. They haven't really planned for the aftermath at all.
通过了一项决议，我想是502号，嗯，他们要求阿根廷人从群岛撤军，决议通过了，因为苏联大使对反法西斯主义者说，你们为此该得一枚嘉德勋章，是的，完全正确，这非常好，嗯，这对苏联来说是个好消息，所以苏联投了弃权票，因为他们和中国一样，对阿根廷和英国的厌恶程度不相上下，所以决议通过了。现在最神奇的是，阿根廷政权，也就是我们上一集聊过的加尔蒂埃里政权，是如此无能。他们根本没有为之后的局面做任何规划。
I think because they just think Britain will accept it as a fait accompli. So they've lined up no diplomatic support. They have nothing. They have no real case. They are just utterly passive. So the British get this UN resolution. So the British have the um right but and there are three key countries three key countries in this drama the first we mentioned
我想是因为他们觉得英国会把这当作既成事实接受。所以他们没有争取到任何外交支持。他们什么都没有。他们没有任何真正的筹码。他们完全处于被动。所以英国人通过了这份联合国决议。所以英国人占了理，不过在这场戏剧中有三个关键国家，我们先前提到了
in the first episode which is argentina's bitterest enemy chile yeah and so chile chile's kind of readiness to help britain is that on the basis of, you know... Hatred of Argentina. My enemy's enemy is my friend. Exactly, yeah. So the Chileans... So there were sort of economic links between the Thatcher government and the Pinochet government because they're obviously both embarked on monetarist experiments.
在第一集里提到了阿根廷死敌智利，是的，智利之所以愿意帮助英国，是不是基于……对阿根廷的恨意。敌人的敌人就是朋友。完全正确，是的。所以智利人……撒切尔政府和皮诺切特政府之间有某种经济联系，因为显然他们都着手推行了货币主义试验。
So their particular style of kind of economic reform. But the Pinochet government is also into the whole kind of attaching electrodes to absolutely singers and very yeah they're very they're very keen yes they they're very keen on them on on domestic repression but you know the british government has no problem with that because they're our cold war allies that's how they perceive it and um the chileans basically say we'll give you our intelligence we'll allow you to base you know the r the rF can have a sort of informal use of a Chilean base I think they just use that for surveillance and stuff
所以他们有那种特定风格的经济改革。但皮诺切特政府同时也热衷于对绝对是歌手的人施加电刑之类的，对，他们非常热衷于国内镇压，但你知道，英国政府对此毫无异议，因为他们是我们的冷战盟友，他们就是这么看的，嗯，智利人基本上说，我们会向你们提供情报，我们允许你们建立基地，你知道，皇家空军可以非正式地使用智利的一个基地，我想他们只是用它来做侦察之类的。
so you know everything that we know you can have any kind of logistical support it can't be done publicly because it breaks the kind of code of South American solidarity but you know we'll give you and so looking very very far ahead that's why when Pinochet gets exiled and comes to Britain,
所以你知道，我们所知道的一切你都可以拿去，任何后勤支援都可以，这不能公开做，因为它打破了南美洲团结的某种准则，但你知道，我们会给你的，所以放眼非常非常长远的未来，这就是为什么当皮诺切特被流放并来到英国时，
Mrs. Thatcher goes for tea with him. Yeah, when he's put under- exactly. Okay, so that's the context for that. The general was very staunch, Tom. Right, so even though it's a crucial part of the British propaganda effort to point out that Argentina is a repressive, fascistic, military yonta. When it comes to Chile, they're our repressive, fascistic, military yonta. I mean, to be fair, just on the Argentines. So the Argentines, another one of the things that they're completely inept at public relations.
撒切尔夫人会去跟他喝茶。是的，当他被软禁在——没错。好的，这就是那事的背景。那位将军非常坚定，汤姆。好吧，所以尽管指出阿根廷是一个压迫性的、法西斯式的军事军政府是英国宣传工作至关重要的一部分。但说到智利，他们就是我们的压迫性的、法西斯式的军事军政府。我是说，公平地说，就阿根廷人而言。所以阿根廷人，他们的另一个完全无能的领域是公共关系。
So the guy they've got commanding their troops in South Georgia is a is a man called i think his name is alfredo astiz a lieutenant and his his nickname is the blonde angel of death yeah that's not good because of his record of murdering nuns so i think um he's probably not the person that the argentines from a pr point of view should have had no charge of that that part of the operation anyway sorry tom okay so so that's ch Chile. And then there's another country led by the man who Mrs. Thatcher described as the staunchest of our friends. And nobody would expect this. And regular listeners who have heard your opinion on the country that this man led may be surprised to learn the identity of this man,
所以他们在南乔治亚岛指挥军队的那个人叫，我想他叫阿尔弗雷多·阿斯蒂斯，是一名中尉，他的外号是“死亡金发天使”，是的，这可不太妙，因为他有谋杀修女的纪录，所以我想，从公关的角度来看，阿根廷人或许真不该让他负责那部分的行动。无论如何，抱歉汤姆。好吧，所以这就是智利。然后还有另一个国家，其领导人被撒切尔夫人描述为我们最坚定的朋友。没有人会料到这一点。而那些听过你对这个人所领导的国家看法的忠实听众，可能会对这个人的身份感到惊讶，
and it was none other than President François Mitterrand. The French were very staunch, Tom. so good to hear that mitterrand mitterrand mitterrand rang mrs that she was the first foreign leader to ring her and he basically said to her france is with you we will give you everything you need you will have our unstinting support and he meant it and do you think why is that oh it's because france can't have regimes nicking islands nicking islands yeah nicking colonial life they've got loads of them is that basically the reason then i think pretty much the reason it's also yes i think it is pretty much they might lose guadeloupe or right i think um so so what has happened is that uh the french
他不是别人，正是弗朗索瓦·密特朗总统。法国人非常坚定，汤姆。听到这个真是太好了，密特朗，密特朗，密特朗给撒切尔夫人打电话，他是第一个打电话给她的外国领导人，他基本上对她说，法国与你们站在一起，我们会给你们需要的一切，你们将得到我们毫不保留的支持，他是认真的。你觉得这是为什么呢？哦，因为法国不能容忍政权抢占岛屿，抢占岛屿，是的，抢占殖民地，他们自己有大把的殖民地呢。这基本上就是原因吗？我想差不多就是这个原因，还有，是的，我想差不多就是这样，他们可能会失去瓜德罗普岛之类的，所以我想，那么，发生的事情是，法国
are one of the biggest military providers to Argentina. So they provide them- Exocet. Exocet missiles and Super Etendard planes. So battle standard planes, I suppose you would call, super battle standard planes. And Mitterrand says, basically, we'll give you all the specs on all the stuff we've sold to Argentina, so you'll know exactly how they work and all that stuff.
是阿根廷最大的军事供应商之一。所以他们提供——飞鱼。飞鱼导弹和超军旗飞机。我想你可以把它们叫做战斗标准飞机，超级战斗标准飞机。密特朗基本上说，我们会把我们卖给阿根廷的所有装备的技术规格都交给你们，这样你们就能确切知道它们是如何运作的以及诸如此类的事情。
And we will not sell any more obviously not to Argentina but we also won't we've got a deal lined up with Peru and we will suspend that because the Peruvians might give some to Argentina so that's an unusual case actually of you know a sort of European competitor basically saying we will put our friendship with you above our own commercial self-interest um it's very striking mrs satchel was always incredibly even though she still kind of gave meter on a handbagging at european summits she was incredibly grateful to meet her on for this but again the weird thing is it wasn't massively publicized and the british public just didn't want to believe it
而且我们不会再出售任何装备，当然不会卖给阿根廷，但我们还有一个与秘鲁达成并准备履行的交易，我们将暂停该交易，因为秘鲁人可能会把一些装备转交给阿根廷。这其实是一个罕见的例子，一个欧洲竞争对手基本上表示，我们将把对你们的友谊置于我们自身的商业利益之上。这非常引人注目。撒切尔夫人总是难以置信——尽管她在欧洲峰会上还是有点给密特朗难堪——但她对密特朗的这一举动极其感激。但奇怪的是，这并没有被大量宣传，英国公众根本不愿相信这一点，
so it didn't enter into the imagination at all but she Mitterrand was quite keen on her, wasn't she? The eyes of Caligula and the mouth of Marilyn Monroe. Yeah, he was. And she was very keen on him. She liked Mitterrand. She didn't mind, you know, people's politics was irrelevant in some ways. The more lounge lizard-like they were, the more Michelle Stasher liked them. So, you know, Mitterrand loves him.
所以这根本没有进入公众的想象中。不过密特朗对她挺感兴趣的，不是吗？卡利古拉的眼睛和玛丽莲·梦露的嘴。是的，他是。而且她对他也非常感兴趣。她喜欢密特朗。她不在乎，你知道，在某些方面人们的政治立场并不重要。他们越是像闲散的纨绔子弟，米歇尔·斯塔夏（撒切尔夫人）就越喜欢他们。所以，你知道，密特朗喜欢她。
Reagan loves him. Helmut Kohl, who's probably- Sausage eater. Absolutely not. Yeah. Okay. So, well, you mentioned Reagan. So Reagan is obviously, the United States is obviously probably the most important.
里根喜欢她。赫尔穆特·科尔，他可能是个——吃香肠的人。绝对不是。好吧。那么，你提到了里根。所以里根显然，美国显然可能是最重要的。
Yeah, it is the most important. And the United States, in its response to the Falklands War, is split. It is. Britain is America's closest ally in NATO but Argentina is a kind of key bulwark of democracy as it's seen even though it's a fascistic dictatorship um and the the figure who is the American figure who is keenest on backing Argentina over Britain is Jean Fitzpatrick Kirkpatrick Kirkpatrick sorry who is the ambassador to the UN.
是的，它是最重要的。美国在对马岛战争的反应上分裂了。确实如此。英国是美国在北约最亲密的盟友，但阿根廷被视为民主的一个关键堡垒，尽管它是一个法西斯独裁政权，嗯，而那个美国人物——最热衷于支持阿根廷而不是英国的美国人物是让·帕特里克，柯克帕特里克，抱歉，她当时是联合国大使。
Yes, exactly. So she's a kind of neoconservative. Jean Kirkpatrick was famous because she's a very strong anti-communist and she had written a big sort of thesis about the difference between totalitarian and authoritarian dictatorships. And she said, authoritarian dictatorships are absolutely splendid. Totalitarian dictatorships are terrible. And we should back Argentina in this dispute. South America is very important to us.
是的，完全正确。所以她算是一名新保守主义者。让·柯克帕特里克很有名，因为她是一位非常坚定的反共人士，她曾写过一篇关于极权主义和威权主义独裁政权之间区别的大型论文。她说，威权主义独裁政权非常棒。极权主义独裁政权糟糕透顶。我们应该在这场争端中支持阿根廷。南美洲对我们非常重要。
The British are kind of yesterday's men. Who cares about them? And she is basically shouted down by the rest of the Reagan administration. His Secretary of Defense, Caspar Weinberger, very pro-British, basically says this stuff. He ends up getting a knighthood, right? He does. And he basically says to the people at the Pentagon, give the Brits whatever they want. Reagan is sort of on the fence because he's having to sort of referee these competing factions within the administration.
英国人已经是昨日黄花。谁在乎他们？而她基本上被里根政府的其他成员大声驳回了。他的国防部长卡斯帕·温伯格非常亲英，基本上就持这种观点。他最后被册封为爵士，对吧？是的。他基本上对五角大楼的人说，给英国人他们想要的一切。里根有点骑墙，因为他不得不调停政府内部这些相互竞争的派系。
But Reagan's heart is very pro-British. He wants to back the British. And when he finally does get off the fence he's actually pretty pretty but but he's sitting he's sitting on the fence while um his uh secretary of state al haig yeah is jetting from washington to london to buenos aires this way and that's trying to patch up uh some kind of compromise and this is the context for what you were saying about mrs thatcher not being as dogmatically set on war as i guess because i guess subsequently every side has an interest in portraying her like that yeah she does because it casts her as the iron lady her enemies her opponents can because it casts her as kind of uncaring and inflexible but actually
但里根内心非常亲英。他想支持英国。当他最终不再骑墙时，其实相当坚定——但他一直在观望，同时他的国务卿亚历山大·黑格，是的，正乘喷气式飞机从华盛顿飞往伦敦又飞往布宜诺斯艾利斯，到处奔波，试图拼凑出某种妥协方案。这就是你之前说撒切尔夫人并不像后来人们描绘的那样在教条式地坚持战争的背景，因为我觉得后来各方都有兴趣把她塑造成那样，是的，她确实如此，因为这把她塑造成了铁娘子，她的敌人和对手可以这样做，因为这把她塑造成冷酷无情且不知变通的形象，但实际上
she is more open to negotiation than the myth would suggest yeah that's absolutely right i mean al haig is a man with an ego the size of the moon, and he basically says, I will personally ensure there is no war. And he does this subtle diplomacy, like his old boss, Henry Kissinger, had done in the 70s. And he comes to Britain, and he basically can get a deal with the British. And the deal is that both sides will withdraw,
她比神话所暗示的更愿意进行谈判。是的，完全正确。我是说，黑格是一个拥有月球般巨大自负的人，他基本上说，我将亲自确保不会发生战争。他进行了精妙的外交，就像他的老上司亨利·基辛格在70年代所做的那样。他来到英国，基本上能与英国人达成一项协议。而协议的内容是双方都撤军，
so the British will agree not to send their fleet too close to the Falklands. The Argentines will withdraw their troops. And then the islands, there are various iterations of this deal, but basically the islands will be administered for the time being by a kind of international condominium,
所以英国人同意不把舰队派得离马岛太近。阿根廷人撤走军队。然后群岛——关于这个协议有各种各样的版本，但基本上群岛将暂时由某种国际共管机构进行管理，
different powers, maybe Britain and Argentina, two of them. And for the next two years and in that time, they'll come to a deal on the sovereignty of the islands. Almost certainly, I think, Tom, that deal would have involved Argentina getting the sovereignty. Because I can't see there's any other compromise that they could possibly have accepted. And the really remarkable thing is that, for example, 14th of April, Mrs. Thatcher tells her cabinet, we have to accept haig's deal you know we can't we have to compromise and this is not the first time she does this by the way
不同的强权，也许是英国和阿根廷，他们两个。并在接下来的两年里，就群岛的主权达成一项协议。汤姆，几乎可以肯定的是，那项协议本会让阿根廷获得主权。因为我想象不出他们还能接受任何其他的妥协。真正引人注目的是，例如，4月14日，撒切尔夫人对她的内阁说，我们必须接受黑格的协议，你知道，我们不能拒绝，我们必须妥协。顺便说一句，这并不是她第一次这样做，
um and and it's you know again this is as you said it's not well known mrs thatcher herself doesn't trumpet this later on so it gets forgotten she talked about it in her memoirs she does but she talks about it in a very evasive, shadowy way. Haig takes the deal. He goes off to Buenos Aires and the Argentines say no. And this is the interesting thing. Because Britain can be seen to compromise. It's very embarrassing for Mrs. Thatcher.
而且，你知道，正如你所说，这并不广为人知，撒切尔夫人自己后来也没有大肆宣扬，所以这件事被遗忘了。她在回忆录里提过吗？她提过，但她是以一种非常规避的、模糊的方式提到的。黑格拿走了协议。他前往布宜诺斯艾利斯，而阿根廷人拒绝了。这就是有趣的地方。因为英国表现出愿意妥协，这让撒切尔夫人感到非常尴尬。
It would have robbed her of that sort of romantic, patriotic role that she was playing. Elizabeth I at Tilbury. Elizabeth I at Tilbury, exactly, or sort of Boudicca. But she could have done it. She could have said, we compromised and we avoided a war. It's absolutely impossible for the Argentines to compromise because all they have is nationalism in their locker. They've sent their troops and then
这会剥夺她所扮演的那种浪漫的、爱国主义的角色。蒂尔贝里的伊丽莎白一世。蒂尔贝里的伊丽莎白一世，没错，或者某种布狄卡。但她本可以做到。她本可以宣称，我们妥协了，我们避免了一场战争。而阿根廷人要妥协是绝对不可能的，因为他们手里除了民族主义什么都没有。他们已经派出了军队，然后
have to withdraw their troops after they've had crowds on the streets of buenos aires cheering and waving argentine flags would be humiliating for them and um they're completely intransigent haig says to them i mean haig says to them at one point if you'll forgive my language he says to his aides the whole thing is a charade a fucking charade these guys are diddling me this is about argentina and then he basically says to galtieri we know exactly what he says he says in the final meeting within a matter of days the british fleet will be upon you those forces are capable of inflicting severe damage on yours i don't for one moment question argentine courage but it cannot prevent your systematic defeat by sophisticated british surface subsurface
在布宜诺斯艾利斯街头挤满欢呼和挥舞阿根廷国旗的人群之后再撤军，对他们来说将是奇耻大辱。而且他们完全冥顽不灵。黑格对他们说——我是说，黑格在某个时刻对他们说，如果原谅我的粗俗用语，他对他的助手们说，这一切都是个骗局，他妈的骗局，这些家伙在耍我，这全是关于阿根廷的事。然后他基本上对加尔蒂埃里说，我们确切知道他说的话，他在最后的会面中说，几天之内，英国舰队就会兵临城下。这些部队有能力对你们造成严重破坏。我一刻也没有怀疑过阿根廷人的勇气，但这无法阻止先进的英国水面、水下
and air power blah blah blah the british will not bear the onus because you were the first to use force and they made a reasonable effort to reach a peaceful settlement there is no escaping the historical responsibility for what now seems inevitable he says this to galtieri galtieri still says no because the argentines also just have it in mind that the british will crumble because of the weather that they'll lose some ships that they'll be able to and all the time do you think what's their take on mrs thatcher do they feel because she's a woman therefore i'm sure do they feel kind of threatened by her but well they don't want to or do they think you know she'll burst into tears and run away?
和空中力量对你们进行系统的击溃，巴拉巴拉巴拉。英国人不会承担责任，因为你们是率先使用武力的一方，而他们为达成和平解决做出了合理的努力。对于现在看来不可避免的后果，历史责任是无可逃避的。他对加尔蒂埃里说了这番话，加尔蒂埃里仍然拒绝，因为阿根廷人脑子里也只是觉得英国人会因为天气而崩溃，他们会损失一些军舰，他们能够——而且一直以来，你觉得他们对撒切尔夫人的看法是什么？他们觉得因为她是个女人，所以——我确信，他们会觉得受到她的威胁吗？或者他们觉得，你知道，她会放声大哭然后跑掉？
I suspect Argentina is not a country in the 70s, 80s. No, it's not a feminist stronghold. It's not renowned for its progressive gender politics, particularly in the army. And I think undoubtedly they would despise her because she's a woman. They despise Britain for having a woman leader, and they see that as part of a sort of enfeeblement. But also, in the Argentine press, they present it always as, have you ever seen these covers of these magazines, Tom?
我猜阿根廷在70、80年代并不是一个——不，它不是一个女权主义堡垒。它不以进步的性别政治闻名，尤其是在军队里。毫无疑问，我认为他们会因为她是个女人而鄙视她。他们鄙视英国有一个女领导人，并将其视为一种虚弱的表现。而且，在阿根廷的媒体上，他们总是把她描绘成——汤姆，你见过这些杂志的封面吗？
They're amazing. They always portray her with an eye patch as a pirate. And there's a brilliant, I can't remember what the periodical is, but we reproduced it in my book, Who Dares Wins, in color. It has a picture of Mrsrs thatcher and it says um pirata brouhaha assassina yeah pirate yeah guilty yeah pirate witch and assassin and they well i'm looking at them now um so that yeah there's one where it's a photo of her and they photoshopped on um an eyepatch but there's one as a fabulous a photo of her and they photoshopped on an eyepatch.
它们太惊人了。他们总是把她描绘成戴着眼罩的海盗。有一个绝佳的——我不记得那是哪本期刊了，但我们在我的书《敢作敢为者胜》（Who Dares Wins）中彩色重印了它。上面有一张撒切尔夫人的照片，写着——嗯，海盗、恶棍、刺客，是的，海盗，是的，有罪，是的，海盗女巫和刺客。他们——嗯，我现在正看着它们——嗯，所以是的，其中一张是她的照片，他们用修图软件给她加上了——一个眼罩，但还有一张棒极了，是她的照片，他们用修图软件给她加上了一个眼罩。
But there's one as a fabulous drawing of her looking very, very kind of haggard and crone-like almost with a pirate's kind of hat on. She's fingering a sword. Yeah, she's got a pirate's hat with a skull and crossbones. That's brilliant. Well, I must try and put that on the tweak advertising this. That's excellent. But Dominic, something that you say in the book, the fact that Mrs. Thatcher was not a man proved an enormous asset. So what do you mean by that? So that's in the context of the British cabinet, is it?
但有一张是她非常绝妙的画作，看起来非常非常憔悴，几乎像个老太婆，戴着海盗式的帽子。她手指划过一把剑。是的，她戴着一顶画有骷髅和交叉骨的海盗帽。太棒了。好吧，我得设法把它发到做广告的推特上。太棒了。不过，多米尼克，你在书中提到过一个事实，撒切尔夫人不是个男人被证明是一项巨大的资产。那你是什么意思？所以这指的是英国内阁的背景，对吧？
So the way she normally handles her business is she's incredibly interfering and bossy. I basically think she knows everybody else's business better than theirs. But this is the one thing that she knows nothing at all about. And nobody expects her to know about it. So she doesn't have a chip on her shoulder about it. No one could possibly expect her to know about tanks and planes and submarines. But she gets rather keen on military men. She loves military men.
她通常处理事务的方式是极其好干涉且专横的。我基本上认为她觉得自己比任何人都懂别人的业务。但这是她唯一一无所知的事情。而且没有人指望她会懂。所以她对此没有什么心理负担。没有人会指望她懂坦克、飞机和潜水艇。但她对军人产生了浓厚的兴趣。她喜欢军人。
She loves listening to them. She doesn't feel she has to compete with them as she does with economists or with her own, particularly her own ministers, who she loves to bully. So for once, I think, in her entire career in government, everybody says she listens. She takes advice. She's very sensible. She doesn't ever interfere. She just lets us get on with it.
她喜欢听他们说话。她不觉得自己需要像跟经济学家或她自己的大臣们竞争那样去跟他们竞争，她特别喜欢霸凌她自己的大臣们。所以破天荒地，我认为在她整个政府生涯中，所有人都说她会倾听。她听取意见。她非常理智。她从不干涉。她只是让我们放手去做。
She gives us clear answers. I mean, all the people who worked with her, all the the military men who often many of them had previously absolutely despised her um they say oh she was a dream to work with you know very decisive and let us get on with it now had she been a the other thing is i suppose you could say had she been a man with experience of war like so many of they all knew i mean they said we know what can go wrong she didn't and that meant that she was ready to go for it and so ready to trust men in braid oh she loved men yeah she loved them when they say yes we can do this and dominic to be fair um it it does go well so the task force does reach the south atlantic after what nine weeks is it no it's three weeks oh three
她给我们清晰的答案。我是说，所有与她共事的人，所有那些以前可能绝对鄙视她的军人们——他们说，哦，跟她共事简直是梦想，你知道的，非常果断，让我们放手去做。现在，如果她是一个——另一件事是，我想你可以说，如果她是一个有战争经验的男人，就像他们中许多人所知道的那样——他们都知道，我是说他们说过，我们知道哪里会出问题。她不知道，这意味着她准备放手一搏，并且愿意信任那些身穿军服的男人。哦，她爱军人，是的，她爱他们。当他们说“是的，我们可以做到”时。多米尼克，说实话，嗯，事情确实进展顺利——所以特遣舰队在九周后到达了南大西洋，是吗？不，是三周。哦，三周
weeks that long well well they're shorter time well no it's um henry leach had said to her she said how long will it take to get ready the the task force he said it'll take three days and she said how long to get to the falklands and he said three weeks she said you mean three days and he said no no no i mean three weeks like it takes ages to get to the falklands um so they sail at the beginning of april they get to ascension island on the 19th of april um they don't land until towards the end of may so is it so actually tom you were right actually it's a very very long protract i mean they they sort of they have to allow time for the diplomatic process to play out and for everybody to catch up in the fleet so it's weeks so for weeks actually nothing really is happening the task force is just it's a 10-week
有那么久吗？好吧，时间更短。好吧，不，亨利·利奇曾对她说——她问他，特遣舰队准备好需要多长时间？他说，需要三天。她又问，到达马岛需要多长时间？他说，三周。她说，你是说三天？他说，不，不，不，我意思是三周，因为去马岛需要很长时间。所以他们在4月初起航，4月19日到达阿森松岛，直到5月底才登陆。所以，实际上，汤姆，你说的其实是对的，这是一个非常非常漫长的、旷日持久的——我是说，他们必须留出时间让外交进程发挥作用，并让舰队中的所有人赶上来。所以需要几周时间。因此，实际上有几周时间什么都没发生，特遣舰队只是在破浪前行。所以这有点像一场板球测试赛，有很长的相持期，然后突然爆发激烈的行动。
campaign all in all but for most of that time the task force is just kind of plowing through the waves so it's a bit like a test match it's kind of long periods and then sudden explosive action well except there's no action at all to start with because basically all that's happening is these blokes are on the ships sunbathing and they're just sort of limbering up but it all doesn't at that point it doesn't really seem real so a lot of the soldiers are saying well you know it'll be actually going to be fighting will we get back in time for the world cup which is happening in spain that summer but dominic one thing that does happen is we mentioned south georgia in the first episode the scrap metal behaved disgracefully by barbecuing a reindeer um and this is this is the first episode. Scrap metal. The scrap metal behaved disgracefully by barbecuing a reindeer.
嗯，除了刚开始时根本没有任何行动，因为基本上发生的事情是，这些家伙在船上晒日光浴，他们只是在做热身运动，但在那个时候，这感觉并不真实。所以很多士兵都在说，好吧，你知道，真的要打仗吗？我们能及时赶回来看今年夏天在西班牙举行的世界杯吗？不过，多米尼克，确实发生了一件事，我们在第一集里提到了南乔治亚岛，废金属队卑劣地烤了一头驯鹿——而这就是第一集。废金属队。废金属队卑劣地烤了一头驯鹿。
And this is the first clash between British and Argentine forces. And it's a total British victory, right? Well, although it's a bit more dramatic than that, Tom. A few helicopters go blown up and things. So I think I said before, the 16th of April, the first aircraft carriers got to Ascension Island. And at that point, there were 127 ships in the fleet.
这是英国军队和阿根廷军队之间的第一次交火。这是一场彻底的英国大捷，对吧？嗯，尽管过程比那要戏剧性一些，汤姆。有几架直升机被炸毁了之类的事。所以我想我之前说过，4月16日，第一艘航空母舰到达阿森松岛。当时舰队里有127艘军舰。
So it's a bloody big fleet. And there's about 10,000 men. And when they get to Ascension Island, they divide off 150 Royal Marines and 70 men from the SAS. And they're basically going to go off to South Georgia, which is, as we said before, hundreds of miles away from the Falkland Islands. It's really important that the government gets an early victory. But South Georgia, it's practically, you're virtually in Antarctica or you're getting on the way to Antarctica. So when the first helicopters go, 21st of April,
所以这是一支规模庞大的舰队。大约有1万人。当他们到达阿森松岛时，他们分出了150名皇家海军陆战队员和70名特种空勤团（SAS）成员。他们基本上要前往南乔治亚岛，正如我们之前所说，那里距离福克兰群岛（马岛）数百英里之遥。政府取得一场早期胜利非常重要。但南乔治亚岛，实际上，你几乎就在南极洲，或者正走在去南极洲的路上。所以当第一批直升机出发时，4月21日，
they drop these blokes. They're on a glacier. The tents blow away. It's kind of Shackleton, the terror style kind of freezing. Monsters lurching up out of freezing conditions. Basically, most of the tents are blown away. There's got about a couple of tents left
他们把这些家伙投放在一座冰川上。帐篷被风吹走了。这简直是沙克尔顿式的、极地恐怖风格的严寒。怪物从冰冻的环境中蹒跚而出。基本上，大部分帐篷都被吹走了。只剩下大概两顶帐篷了，
and they're all, some of the men are in the tents. The other men are trying to shovel snow away and it's just awful. And they basically have to radio and say, come and get us. This isn't going to work at all. The helicopters then crash.
他们全都——有些人在帐篷里。其他人则试图铲除积雪，情况糟透了。他们基本上不得不通过无线电求救，说，来接我们吧。这根本行不通。然后直升机坠毁了。
Mrs. Thatcher gets the news the helicopters have crashed, and she thinks the men are dead. So she starts crying. It's the first moment of casualty. It's the first operation, really, of the war, and it's all gone wrong. And then she gets the news that a third helicopter has got there and got them out and she's absolutely on cloud nine and i think that that's a real psychological turning point for her because that really emboldens her um in future she's going to be much less keen on peace and she starts to
撒切尔夫人听到直升机坠毁的消息，以为这些人全死了。于是她开始哭泣。这是战争中的第一起伤亡时刻。这可以说是战争的第一次行动，结果全搞砸了。然后她接到消息说第三架直升机赶到并把他们救了出来，她顿时欣喜若狂。我认为这是她心理上的一个真正的转折点，这极大地坚定了她以后的决心——在未来，她对和平的兴趣会大大减少，她开始
identify with the men and they're slightly our boys yeah our boys our brave boys our lads all that sort of stuff from that point onwards then on the 25th which is a sunday mrs touches at checkers and she gets the news that um they're going to start try the operation again this time it all goes absolutely splendidly they they attack an argentine submarine which is at south georgia called the santa fe and they cripple it um the the brit British commandos kind of arrive. The Argentines don't even fire a shot. They just basically give up completely straight away. The scrap metal-
认同这些士兵，他们有点像我们的男孩——是的，我们的男孩，我们勇敢的男孩，小伙子们，诸如此类的话。从那时起，在25日，那是一个星期天，撒切尔夫人在契克斯别墅，她得到消息说——他们要再次尝试这次行动。这一次一切都进行得非常顺利。他们袭击了停在南乔治亚岛的一艘阿根廷潜水艇，名叫“圣达菲”号，并将其重创。英国突击队员抵达了。阿根廷人甚至没有开枪。他们基本上立刻就完全投降了。废金属——
So are they conscripts? Yeah, they are. I mean, almost all the Argentine- I mean, there are obviously some professional troops, but a large proportion of their troops in the Argentine army are conscripts. Because if you're a conscript, you wouldn't want to take on the SAS, would you?
所以他们是义务兵吗？是的，他们是。我是说，几乎所有的阿根廷军队——我是说，当然有一些职业军人，但阿根廷军队中很大一部分士兵都是义务兵。因为如果你是个义务兵，你不会想跟SAS（特种空勤团）硬碰硬，对吧？
No, I mean, these are very young guys. I mean, boys, boys basically from Buenos Aires who are in this freezing place they've no idea where they are bloody awful there's a lot of scrap metal dealers and suddenly the SAS pitch up so they're fun yeah so they surrender and um so that night there is this incredibly dramatic moment are you going to give us a rendition of that tom or is that no i'm not i think we're going to stop at this point oh no that is a cliffhanger so that's a cliffhanger so a lot of people won't be able to sleep they won't be able to sleep with excitement well in that case they'll have to join the the members
不，我是说，这些都是非常年轻的小伙子。我是说，基本上是来自布宜诺斯艾利斯的男孩，他们在这个冰冻的地方，根本不知道自己在哪里，糟糕透顶。有很多废金属商，突然SAS冒了出来，所以他们觉得完蛋了，是的，所以他们投降了。因此，那天晚上有一个极其戏剧性的时刻。汤姆，你要给我们朗诵一段吗？还是说——不，我不打算朗诵，我想我们到此为止。哦，不，这真是个悬念。所以这是一个悬念，很多人会睡不着觉，他们会兴奋得睡不着觉。好吧，在这种情况下，他们只能加入会员俱乐部了，
club won't they very good the rest is historypod.com we will kick off with my sensational impression of mrs satchel's response to the triumph at South Georgia. And then we will look at the task force moving in the Falklands, the sinking of the Belgrano, the sinking of HMS Sheffield, the press reaction in Britain, which is extraordinary. And then how Britain ends up taking the Falklands back. Hasta luego. Bye bye. how Britain ends up taking the Falklands back. Hasta luego. Bye-bye. Thanks for listening to The Rest Is History. For bonus episodes, early access, ad-free listening, and access to our chat community, please sign up at restishistorypod.com. That's restishistorypod.com. I'm Marina Hyde. And I'm Richard Osman. And together we host The Rest
对吧？非常棒。therestishistorypod.com。我们将以我对撒切尔夫人对南乔治亚岛大捷反应的轰动性模仿作为开场。然后我们将探讨特遣舰队挺进马岛、贝尔格拉诺号被击沉、谢菲尔德号驱逐舰被击沉、英国媒体异常的反应，以及英国最终如何夺回马岛。再见。拜拜。英国最终如何夺回马岛。再见。拜拜。感谢收听《历史的余烬》（The Rest Is History）。想要收听独家加更节目、提前解锁内容、无广告收听体验以及加入我们的聊天社区，请访问 restishistorypod.com 注册。网址是 restishistorypod.com。我是玛丽娜·海德。我是理查德·奥斯曼。我们共同主持《娱乐的余烬》
Is Entertainment. It's your weekly fix of entertainment news, reviews, splash of showbiz gossip. And on our Q&A, we pull back the curtain on entertainment and we tell you how it all works we have just launched our members club if you want ad free listening bonus episodes and early access to live tickets
（The Rest Is Entertainment）。这里有你每周必看的娱乐新闻、评论和一丝不苟的娱乐圈八卦。在我们的问答环节中，我们将揭开娱乐圈的神秘面纱，告诉你这一切是如何运作的。我们刚刚推出了会员俱乐部，如果你想要无广告收听体验、加更节目以及优先购买现场活动门票的权利，
head to therestisentertainment.com There aren't comments yet for this episode. Click on any sentence in the transcript to leave a comment.
请前往 therestisentertainment.com。本集还没有评论。点击文稿中的任意句子即可留下评论。